[Applause]
[Music]
i think nobody will be surprised if i
say that immigration is one of the most
important issues
in international politics and certainly
both in
europe and in the united states lately
everything
related to this issue takes over most of
the news and the front pages of the
newspapers
immigration is the fault in all of the
problems that we're having
what the administration has decided to
do is to separate
children from their parents to try to
send a message
that if you cross the border with
children
your children are going to be ripped
away from you that's traumatizing to the
children who are innocent
victims and it is contrary to
our values in this country the united
states will not be
a migrant camp and it will not be a
refugee holding
facility
colombia venezuela
without going any further here at
visualpolitik we've already spoken a few
times about this subject and soon we're
going to post a special video
first on our patreon and then here on
youtube commenting and dismantling many
of the myths and
half truths that exist on this subject
and just before we get into the me to
today's video speaking of patreon let me
thank everyone who is supporting us on
patreon and everyone who just watches us
we're about to cross the half million
subscriber marks that's pretty amazing
and we couldn't do that without you
especially the people who do support us
like i say on patreon because of that we
are now publishing 50
more videos and we're now preparing lots
of surprises and of course
all of the other things that we have
promised you but for now let's just
crack on
[Music]
this time i'd like to share some
reflections with you some
ideas which i think we should keep in
mind when we're talking about
immigration
this is particularly important if we
consider that lately mistrust
fear and anti-immigration political
speeches well they're very much alive
get out of my country i can still hear
that sentence with
absolute clarity as if it occupies a
specific place in my mind
it's a scar deep within the man who said
get out of my country
was a trump supporter i know this
because he was wearing a pin
identifying the then candidate on one of
his lapels but most of all
i know this because of the way he said
it to me he looked me straight in the
eyes
pointed a finger at me and shouted jorge
ramos
a journalist from univision and a u.s
citizen who was born in mexico
one of the most typical and popular
arguments of those who oppose
immigration
is stating that immigrants take our jobs
and take the money back to their own
countries
you know as long as we're not talking
about messi cristiano ronaldo nadal
or maybe the rolling stones there of
course there's
no problem which is perhaps a bit
hypocritical don't you think so now we
come to the question
why do people decide to emigrate who are
these people who pack their bags
and leave their land who benefits from
all of this movement and in general why
is there such a negative perception
of this phenomenon well in this video
i'm going to try and answer some of
those questions but
first i think it's time we took a look
back at how it all began
when why and where by the way what would
you say if i told you that
in some way you're also an immigrant
well listen up
the origin
from the very beginnings of humanity
people moved basically their motivation
was to find food which forced them
to move continuously from one place to
another of course back then
borders didn't exist the only limitation
to moving from one place to another was
how far one could travel
but of course all this began to change
when modern societies emerged that is
when communities settled in a particular
place where they worked to produce
food tools and everything they needed to
trade
and to live
now one thing we can ask ourselves here
is did the migration phenomenon
disappear with this new way of life
well no not at all
see once the first modern societies
established themselves in certain places
and governments began to emerge
back around 3000 bc migration didn't
stop although
motivations did change two large
migration groups were created so to
speak two groups with really different
motivations
on the one hand there was conquering and
on the other hand there was
searching for opportunities
[Music]
the first conquests were movements
carried out by societies that had
achieved a higher level of development
and who wanted to take advantage of it
to gain wealth from the people they
conquered
[Music]
this involved a migratory movement from
the most developed countries
to the less developed countries to
monopolize their resources
[Music]
although this phenomenon wasn't
exclusive to any continent the case
that we all know best is perhaps that of
the europeans who managed to control
almost the
entire world starting with america of
course this type of migration it doesn't
look
anything like the migration that we have
today the second type of migration
though
it certainly does we're talking about
the peaceful mobilization of millions of
people who seek
to escape their territory of origin to
reach another territory where they can
find
new and better opportunities
therefore in this case their drive is to
search for economic improvements and
sometimes
also to escape political and religious
persecution
therefore in general we're talking about
peaceful migrations from the least
developed countries to the most
developed countries
which is something like the opposite of
conquests
well the first large case happened at
the end of the middle ages when
cities grew and people began to leave
the countryside to
move to these cities in any case this it
was a really
slow process but everything changed with
the arrival
of the industrial revolution
[Music]
it's estimated that between 1850 and
1930 almost
60 million europeans which was a huge
percentage of the population at that
time
emigrated to the americas to countries
like the us canada brazil and argentina
[Music]
that is to say despite all the political
discourse against immigration the truth
is that
europe has a well-defined history as an
immigrant territory europeans first
emigrated massively from the countryside
to the cities then they
moved around the world and now in our
times millions and millions of europeans
have
left their land to live in another
european union country
and what the united states almost all of
its population
if not all of it comes from other
countries or lives in territories that
belonged to other countries
as is the case of the lands of
california new mexico and texas which
historically belonged to mexico
[Applause]
so in a way we're all really the
descendants of immigrants
in fact if we take the current
anti-immigration demonstrations to the
extreme we could
state that we are all immigrants in the
regions
in which we live now the question we
must ask is
well what are the consequences of all of
that could it have something to do with
the fact that most of the richest and
most developed countries
in the world have been exposed to the
migratory process
well listen up
what history tells us
[Music]
was it loud or say clear most immigrants
share a common goal
to achieve a better life and more
progress
it's true some people with deep pockets
are a good standard of living move from
their country to grow professionally
live new experiences or maybe just live
differently these immigrants who
usually arrive with a full wallet almost
never
awaken anyone's mistrust
however the same does not apply to
people who are
escaping hunger misery all kinds of
political religious and social
persecutions
these are immigrants who arrive with an
empty wallet
in search of new opportunities this type
of immigration is by far the most
important and of course the one that
generates the greatest mistrust
hostility and criticism
however this immigration is almost
identical to our ancestors we're talking
about people who are risking
their lives and who decided to leave
everything behind which
is certainly not easy and all for what
well the same as always to
achieve a better future to work and to
prosper in a lawful way little is more
extraordinary than the decision to
migrate
the accumulation of emotions and
thoughts which finally leads a family to
say farewell to a community where it has
lived for centuries
to abandon old ties and familiar
landmarks and to sail
across dark seas to a strange land
john f kennedy president of the united
states of america
tell me who built america who promoted
the extraordinary economic takeoff that
argentina saw at the end of the 19th
century well
folks it was the immigrants and the
descendants of the immigrants
so why do we think of things as
different today
but of course when economic data shows
that immigration drives growth and
development due to higher employment
levels entrepreneurship and productivity
then
anti-immigration critics well they make
up other excuses
we're going to talk about them one by
one in a future video
with data in hand but today i'd like to
end this video with a reflection on one
of the most
important myths fear and crime
[Music]
when mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best
they're not sending you they're sending
people that have lots of problems
and they're bringing those problems with
us they're bringing drugs
they're bringing crime they're rapists
one of the most
widely spread myths is that immigrants
especially undocumented immigrants the
so-called illegals
are the ones responsible for most crimes
and delinquency well you know what the
data
actually says that the opposite is true
now it is true that there are legal and
illegal immigrants who commit crimes
however let's look at an example let's
look at what happens
in the country with the most immigrants
in the world the united states
see between 1990 and 2013 the number of
undocumented immigrants known as illegal
immigrants went from
three and a half million people to
approximately 11 million
however in that same period according to
the fbi the number of violent crimes
dropped by
[Music]
surprised well if we take the crime data
into account you really shouldn't be
see according to an immigration policy
center study only 1.6 percent of
immigrant men aged 18 to 39
end up in prison among those born in the
united states the data
is 3.3 percent so more than double
check out this graph on crime levels in
texas which is one of the states with
the most legal and
illegal immigrants
[Music]
yes we can agree that we need to reorder
the migratory processes but
stigmatizing immigrants and outlawing
their condition only favors
the human trafficking mafias the
evidence is
clear immigrants try to reach countries
with higher levels of freedom and more
open economic systems
in short places where they can work and
enjoy life without
fear therefore perhaps a good measure
and
maybe the only one to control the
migratory flow is a remote
trade private investment and democratic
institutions in the countries that
people are leaving but
meanwhile developed countries can take
advantage of immigration in the same way
as
other societies did throughout history
immigrants dear viewer
they want to work and they want to
prosper
so i really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos also don't
forget to check out our friends at
reconsider media they provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine and don't forget as i said this
channel
it's all possible because of patreon and
our patrons on that platform
please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always
thank you for watching the united states
will not be
a migrant camp and it will not be a
refugee holding
facility it won't be